One fifth of seafood is thought
to be caughtillegally
or is simply unreported.
If you can't see it, you can't manage it.
And I know fromexperience,
you can't monitor the whole
ocean from the decks of ships.
Using GPS locationdata,
Global Fishing Watch built the
first-ever live stream map
tomonitor the industrial fishing fleet.
When we were working with our
partners in Japan andSouth Korea,
they told us there was illegal fishing
suspected in North Korean waters.
But when we first took a
look on our map, we could see
very little fishing because thosevessels
were not sharing their GPS location data,
as they should.
We call them “dark vessels.”
Andgenerally, dark vessels are up to no good.
So we had to turn to other sources of data.
We lookedat satellite-based radar
and optical imagery,
and we lit that region up.
We revealedan armada
of almost 1,000 vessels.
The techniques we used to illuminate
what washappening in North Korea,
we can use anywhere
and everywhere to make the invisible visible.
We can end pirate fishing.
And we can transformocean management
for the common good of all.